Allisyn war and her sister Shelby Lin
are both acclaimed singer songwriters
Alison with an Oscar nomination and
Shelby with a Grammy Award but they also
share a childhood marked by one
devastating moment when their father
shot their mother and then turned the
gun on himself
in her stunning new memoir blood Allison
Moore writes about the legacy of that
murder-suicide to sister's lifelong
quest to make peace with their past and
the power of human resilience we talked
to Allison recently for her first and
only TV interview for most of Allison
Moore's life the story of her parents
has been hiding in her music every
record I've ever made has got some song
on it that has something to do with this
there's something to do with my parents
over the past few years the 47 year old
singer has been researching her mother
and father those autopsy reports has
sent away for especially their deaths I
want to know why so that I can come to
terms and say okay well what I'm really
trying to do is forgive can you do that
yeah I needed to do it so that I could
be happy in her new memoir blood Maurer
tries to find proof that as she writes
we weren't and aren't ruined by it all
I'm still trying not to be the daughter
of a murderer
I'm still trying not to be the daughter
of an abused and murdered woman I'm
still trying to redeem them Franklin and
Lynn Maurer
raised their daughters in Frank Vil
Alabama
Allyson and her older sister Shelby grew
up surrounded by music that's the family
singing and playing together in the mid
70s their father was a teacher and an
aspiring songwriter but Franklin Moore
also had a drinking problem and a mean
streak he used to say a prayer every
night mm-hmm what was the prayer please
God don't let daddy hurt mama and I
would say it over and over what was it
you felt in the house terror one day
while playing with Shelby Allison fell
off the family horse our daddy hit my
sister in the face for it
when your daddy beats the crap out of
you how are you supposed to feel like
you're worth anything
in 1986 Lynn finally left her husband
and moved with the two girls to this
rental house in the early hours of
August 12th Franklin paid a visit you
heard the shots that morning mm-hmm they
woke me it was Shelby I went outside
right of course on the front lawn Shelby
found their father had shot their mother
and then turned the gun on himself
I think he just broke Shelby at 17 and
Allison 14 were suddenly orphans it's a
difficult thing to walk through the
world and not belong to anyone
so we belong to each other we've always
felt like that you've never been back
there have you no I've never been back
to that house it has never stopped
haunting her the tragedy colors
everything and all the good feels a bit
bittersweet this is mama pregnant with
[ __ ] mementos of her parents are all
over Allison's Nashville home my mama
was a great mama and she is why I'm okay
she is why my sister is okay what did
she give you
she never ever let me believe that I was
not loved if she has often doubted her
father's affections she still held on to
his hat it travels with you it travels
with me his briefcase and his guitar how
do you feel about him now I feel nothing
but how did you get to that
investigation willingness and having a
little boy how did that make a
difference I got to see and experience a
little boy and know that my daddy was
one one time this my son John Henry
Allison's son bless his heart is
autistic she knows one day she'll have
to explain the family history did you
figure out what you're gonna tell John
Henry probably that his grandparents
were troubled and beautiful like we all
are this is an absolutely stunning book
blood you're just a brilliantly
beautifully written book and she's
released an album as well it sort of
goes along with it it's an incredible
story you wonder when you pick it up how
can you tell this yeah she's done it
it's really it's really what she's
stunning and powerful I marvel at her
ability to forgive especially when she
was 14 and her sister 17 you're old
enough to really understand yes yes and
the abuse that you've seen she describes
essentially being on a hamster wheel for
most of her life trying to reach some
elusive peace I said did you get there
and she said no I just got off very
powerful piece bracingly articulated on
areas of life that a lot of us keep
silent about yep Thank You Anthony